welcome back to las vegas now it's a day
to celebrate mathematics and sweets it's
national pie day as in 3.14
and the silverton is here to celebrate
please help us welcome chef ashley
archer who brought in
what else but pies thanks for being here
thank you for having us yeah we've been
up all night baking fresh pies because
today in sundance cafe um anybody who
orders a an entree gets a free slash a
free slice of pie wow so do they get a
choice between our homemade apple okay
our cherry or our blueberry okay you
can't go wrong with any of those no i
mean i'm a pie guy look at me
well i have to tell you anyone who knows
me knows that i am not a math gal that's
probably always been my worst subject in
school but i am a pie gal so i'm really
excited that you're here and i can't
just look at these pies i need to try
one so i want you to pick your favorite
and i got to take a bite well my
favorite is the blueberry okay it's
actually one of the new menu items that
we added to the menu about three months
ago so
uh it's one of mine whenever i dine in
sundance i definitely go for the
blueberry book okay i'm going in for a
bite and tell us a little bit about
sundance and what else you guys have
there and some of the entrees that you
could order that you could pair with us
sundances our cafe
there
we have everything from a great
selection of breakfast items to hearty
lunch items big sandwiches big portions
our chicken fried steak is something
for late night meal late night snack
that can really you know help eliminate
the edge of maybe the events of the
evening right so uh yes absolutely it's
just a it's just a great variety our
tomato caprese burrata salad is a new
item that we added that's really fresh
and exciting so you'll find a little bit
of everything and i think what's kind of
unique about it is that
whatever you're whatever you're in the
mood for whether it's a pizza whether
it's steak and eggs whether it's a prime
rib dip sandwich we have it hey i feel
like you should order a pizza because
that's also considered a pie so you
could have a pizza pie and an actual pie
would that be considered pie square
i think so i don't know i told you don't
ask me math questions but it sounds good
to me and i was a little distracted
while you're talking because this is
absolutely amazing i'm glad it's a new
addition to the menu and you also
obviously pair the pie with ice cream
you guys have other ice creams or things
on the menu we have a nice gelato
selection if you come to the front of
the restaurant we have a beautiful
gelato case with a million different
flavors
we make a lot of our ice creams in-house
our sorbets are all made in-house so um
yeah you get a ton of different things
and we're always constantly changing
those to really kind of go with the
seasonality and what's available hey you
can't go wrong with any of that and i'm
just going to keep enjoying national pie
day with this delicious pie and real
quick if people want to come celebrate
with you how late are you know you guys
open and can they just come in and take
advantage of the deal today we're open
until seven uh from seven a.m until 10
p.m during the week and then on saturday
fridays and saturdays during the weekend
we're open till midnight okay awesome
well you have until 10 p.m to go try a
pie it's delicious take my word for it
next up i'm going in for the apple thank
you so much for being here happy
national pie day jc i'll send it over to
you save me some pies